[Music]
we're all quarantined
we're all affected by their own overall
not me I go out every day so this you
are I got everything I go to the
hospitals make sure they're doing their
jobs and then I go hands with the cops
he makes out with all the patients to
make sure that they're not infected
that's good that's good the only one way
to find out that it's antibodies yeah
you know sue they're the stop lines
licks it just to make sure it's clean
yep true true so in fact you are the
healthiest person you actually got all
the disease tested yourself by going
into the battlefield you vaccinated
yourself I do feel like that's why my
immune system stronger cuz you're
Vietnamese yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
even meat you are strong though they
never got I heard it was like something
about like the most people that are
dying are like super deficient in like
vitamin D yeah a lot of people that die
they have yeah vitamin D deficiency but
I mean people with weak immune systems
have vitamin D deficiency
look at my skin color I got all this
vitamin D I'm very chronically deficient
in vitamin D you are yeah but I think it
held it at an urban all day I always try
to go outside and run but I think it was
because of my birth control so that's
why I got off birth control a lot of
people I think don't know that they're
low on it because they're out in the Sun
I wasn't even wearing sunscreen like
which is bad but like I was getting a
lot of Sun but chronically low and yeah
I think it was birth control for yeah
that misses up your mood horny you're a
musician yeah when I got off of it you
felt better yeah that's good bark
control great for cream pies horrible
for the body we still cream pies we're
just willing to accept the baby now even
in this time I just like I monitor it on
an ovulation app yeah we're like we're
doing the reverse now yeah oh you know
I'm you're later or whatever it's good
it's safe to have sex now when we have
sex
natural way but yes humans are affected
by the Rona's
but not only humans animals are too and
an aquarium in japan the dolphin got
[ __ ] up no the eels one that yields
around you and make you listen to me go
way way way eels got Corona
no but the eels are being affected by
the fact that
no one is going to the aquarium leave
their saddles I guess you're getting
scared
so they're getting all shy all these
eels are getting so shy
it's so this aquarium in japan is in
tokyo they are they were asking people
volunteers to call in introduce go know
the face i faces because they're not
seeing any people go by and so they're
getting scared of humans and then it's
making it hard for the staff to check on
them and check on their health because
there's like hiding under the sand when
humans walk by which they used to not
least i'd like to scare humans they call
it a face time and they like are told
the wave but not make noises leave it to
the Japanese people feel like you got
some cue - its ally help animals out and
stuff well Japanese people have the the
virtual was it called um graduation we
have the robot smile faces oh yeah so
you could actually go it's like a bunch
of iPad connected to like the robot that
just has wheels on a stick and they kind
of go in order with like the faces of
each person on the iPad that walks up
and I guess they get presented something
and it goes a robot toy it's kind of
weird though cause it's like but they
have like ten of them so do the faces
switch out and then it goes back up
again but you get to I guess live out a
graduation of some sort ceremony yeah
these are what this is what the the Eels
look like oh I been there yeah I could
tell from this yeah I know that aquarium
it's on a huge-ass skyscraper but you
saw like a second look like diglettz ya
wait they're like fish ID burro there's
so small and they [ __ ] get shy now
know this whole thing where you've got
electric ones yeah like a little mermaid
yeah like a moray eel
it's so cool cuz they look like
eat stuff while they're there yeah they
got penguins there and that's it's a
pretty cool aquarium is this the same
aquarium where they let the Penguins
roam around because there's nobody there
oh I don't know man about that but there
are like penguins like this big and it
and inside it looks like a cam girl's
place cuz it's purple and lit all weird
purple purple lighting you know like
like yeah it's a it's a it's a stream
like a cam girl stream there was an
aquarium where they let the penguins
really like visit the other exhibits and
you can see the pictures of the Penguins
looking at the fish one day that's a
pretty cool query of no it's right next
to this thing called the sky tree which
is the tallest building in Tokyo and
it's like in what say Leo could you tell
it was that it was the South's and you
stand up the the way that it is is they
have a bunch of acquaintance in the
middle like that just a tendon that
looks like a pet store you have like a
lot of Tanks like that just set up like
this and on the walls they have more so
you could go on every aisle like that
and that's one of them and that really
it's so cool that we if you see it once
you guys will remember cuz you huh I've
never seen any aquarium that has yeah it
looks like just like a pet store I mean
not many aquariums can remind you of
chem girls either so that's very
memorable but on the bottom floor they
got all these penguins that are like
this big and they just [ __ ] jump
around and it's [ __ ] so cool yeah I'm
in a while I know cuz you don't support
animal cruelty but I do is that animal
cruelty like the aquarium get patted
also you ask man wait aquarium by
housing fish I think like the long beach
one is okay right
Aquarium of the Pacific know what let me
do fish even realize that they're an
aquarium I don't know some of them got
sea otters they say goldfish memories
are only 30 seconds you ever look at
someone stationary like that sucks
some people do do that really wow that
sucks is here yeah just going in circles
and shade your
mr. circles could be getting eaten by
sharks true we're protecting them now
it's their free choice too that's true
they should choose they should be able
to choose any one much harder than being
domesticated I guarantee you that [ __ ]
oh yeah in nature they're gonna be shot
by poachers they're gonna being it's
better to be our entertainment don't you
feel like that's what the government's
doing to us now they're like you're
safer here it's okay keep me in this
facade in your government programs I
need they're like Jael I know so much
okay have you guys ever seen this lion
fight this a water buffalo
so was a lion that has got like this out
in the water in the wild I forgot what
kind of disease it had like shingles or
something but it had some sort of
disease so the lion pack or he kicked
them out Alice did so like the loser of
the liar so this line is out to defend
itself and it finds like this buffalo so
it's like I'm hungry I'm gonna kill this
buffalo but the Buffalo of course is
like I'm not gonna let you kill me so
they get into a fight and the the lion
gets like horned a couple times and
there's just so much trauma that happens
on both ends they both died that's
nature that's because people don't
realize like lions they actually hunt in
packs because if it is one-on-one a lot
of these herbivores are so [ __ ]
jacked and big they can kill they just
don't have the instinct to kill but they
can kill like a predator see you can't
get yoked on a plant-based diet these
two guys they killed each other and then
they're just now laying out and then
that's what nature is yeah the people
they think predators are predators or
they think like prey or prey it's not
that simple
like when you have a life isn't like we
have a pet snake like you're not really
supposed to put a live mouse in there
because they attack it you can scratch
the freezer or something so it gets like
all slow some people just grab the
tennis
we have we had a pet snake for a little
bit that's what we did we hold the pet
store we buy the the feeder rats so
they're meant to die
Peter record their immune system and all
a [ __ ] so they're not strong so they got
like a weird tumor to possibly yeah so
then yeah they give you it give it to
you in like a paper bag and then once
you have that paper bag and get home I
just how come it doesn't chew through
the paper bag and run away maybe it's
not smart in the feeder as it sucks yeah
it's a beauty rest
yeah Theater feelings too they do they
do there's a more humane way to put them
down tutors supposed to like be a little
more hands-on like twisting Eric snap
something and that's the neck area but I
didn't ever want to touch it in person
like you never wanted to put it in like
a race car and then go to a car crash
and paralyzed like a toy car yeah a
little too like RC cars go bang and it
dies in a car crash
oh poor rats they died in a car crash at
save them no you know what's weird
I could all day grab a fish no feelings
boom hit him with the hammer cut it up
clean it whatever look but when it comes
to mammals like furry creatures I didn't
grow up doing that [ __ ] so it's not like
there's no life attached I mean you
could try to just die if you try
cuddling with it anyway yeah whether or
not scared it kind of looks the same
that's the part of me that makes me be
I'm a psychopath sometimes cuz sometimes
I'd be like hugging the dog I love you
so furry oh my Pam but if you bite me
I'll just stab wounds no hesitation yeah
yeah it's funny because I know those
bodies you know it's weird cuz you know
other people don't think that way but
also it's just a curiosity I think more
than anything it's not like I'm looking
forward to my dog turning on me no but
there's a natural instant that you have
two things that are cute to hurt I'm not
talking about that
it's cute might and then I'm gonna stab
the [ __ ] out of you at the same time
Rome as a natural instinct of her cuties
something about like why do you yeah why
do you want to squeeze in I don't want
to hurt him either
dude my cat's almost scratched my
eyeball out one time and I still was
like I hate that I mean it you didn't
mean it
that's why I do my dog because I feel
like if I go hunting I'll dress I'll be
you know I'll do it well I'm like dying
inside but my one side is like I need to
learn how to do this because I'm so
curious yeah see what it tastes like
and I want to learn how to do this if
I'm trapped in the wild right do you
think hunting is more humane than having
them grow up on a farm being treated bad
I don't know about the moral aspect of
it but I'm thinking more of like the
natural side like imagine eating meat
that was naturally like raised versus
like a cow that's corn-fed so that's
kind of where my mind is that and I'm
trying to there's so many things going
on right so like my curiosity is there
what does like a wild caught animal
taste like and also how do I learn the
skill like what most humans used to know
for thousands of years is how to dress
proper way and all that stuff and that's
that side but as that's being filled
like fulfilled and I'm learning it I'm
hurting inside because I'm like this is
Bambi and it's cute the other side is
like I'm kind of happy I'm doing this -
so it's conflicting well so you're
learning survival skills I also just
think like people that shoot animals to
eat them that's like a different thing
than just just to have that luxury yeah
waste I mean why would you waste good
meat yeah so my I guess my carrier has
curiosities there but then the other
side is like I can eat beans and survive
- I know a lot of bull hunters so they
aim for the heart to put it down ASAP
because they're actually thinking in the
humane way and if they miss and if they
have to take another shot they actually
feel really bad they have to bleed up
yeah they feel really nice let's hike
for two miles to
[Music]